[Musique]
la première mission qui était celle de
monsieur alexandre benalla c'était de
m'appuyer dans l'organisation des
déplacements nationaux
je voulais dire donc là je veux tu ouvre
à nouveau une parenthèse m'appuyer ça
veut dire la possibilité pour lui de
faire des missions préparatoires
il en a fait très peu je les ai
quasiment tout fait au niveau national
personnellement eu égard à l'enjeu d'un
déplacement du président de la
république mais il en a fait par
ailleurs il est dans la pratique que
j'ai instauré avec mes équipes de faire
en sorte qu'un de mes oies des adjoints
soient présents quelques heures avant
l'arrivée du président de la république
sur un déplacement et donc mais
d'arriver à de très nombreuses reprises
conduit très nombreuses reprises
on a dû organiser qu'elle est une
centaine de déplacements du président de
la république en un an et trois mois en
national à l'international
donc de l'envoyer en avance de phase
pour vérifier que le dispositif mis en
place
ils étaient stabilisés et donc il a fait
ses missions dites contre guillemets de
précurseur je suis dit blessé d'un
affreux jargon auprès des premières
missions l'organisation de déplacements
nationaux
je veux fortement vous dire sur ce point
là que monsieur benalla était très
précis dans l'organisation de dans ses
fonctions et que vous savez l'importance
qu'accordent les préfets dans
l'organisation des déplacements du
président de la république et que jamais
je n'ai entendu un préfet de la
république se plaindre de ce qu'a pu
faire monsieur ben alla dans ses
missions préparatoires ou de précurseur
vous en avez d'ailleurs je crois
entendre d'une 2
fera pas qu'ils aient qu'ils aient pu
dire quoi que ce soit sur le viol vous
avez deuxième d'autres circonstances
pardon sur cette centaine de voyages
vous avez entendu des préfet se plaindre
au chef de cabinet du président de la
république du comportement de notre
collaborateur tout deuxièmement
peut-être que j'ai oublié une négation
mais donc je répète jamais aucun préfet
de la république ne s'est plaint de
monsieur benalla dans l'organisation de
ses déplacements mais j'y reviendrais
tout à l'heure parce que vous
m'interrogez certainement sur
l'existence d'autres plaintes il n'y en
a pas eu
deuxièmement deuxièmement deuxièmement
comme les autres chargés de mission de
l'elysée l'organisation des événements
au palais de l'elysée ça va du
rendez-vous à la réception
mobilisant plus de 1200 invités par des
très gros événement organisé au palais
de l'elysée troisièmement la
coordination des deux services la
coordination et c'est comme ça que nous
l'avons voulue sous l'autorité du
directeur de cabinet donc pas la mienne
la coordination des deux services de
sécurité de l'elysée
le gspr elle commandement militaire en
quoi consistait cette coordination
parce que vous allez me poser la
question très simplement nous avons vu
en arrivant au palais de l'elysée que
deux services de sécurité se côtoyer que
sur des sujets très qui n'ont rien à
voir d'ailleurs avec l'exercice de
prérogatives de sécurité il y avait une
meilleure coexistence a organisé entre
notamment sur les questions
je suis désolé ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
sans doute parce que vous attendez mais
en tous les cas sur des choses très
prosaïque tels que le parc automobile
savoir comment faire en sorte par
exemple pour que le parc automobile du
j'espère soit rénové et réhaussée
organiser la coexistence de ces deux
services par rapport aux résidences du
président de la république donc des
choses très très administrative est
absolument pas en lien avec une
immixtion de quelque nature que ce soit
dans le commandement des deux chefs de
service que ce soit le chef du gspr où
le général commandant militaire du
palais
voilà quel était qu'elles sont quels
étaient les missions d'alexandre benalla
j'y ajoute également mais nous le
faisions tous également la préparation
des déplacements non officielle du
président de la république mais alors ça
c'est quelque chose qui fait je crois
beaucoup parlé mais le président de la
république
même lorsque son déplacement n'est pas
médiatisé et qu'ils se déplacent ça se
prépare ça se prépare
et ça se prépare en termes
d'organisation en terme d'accueil
je veux pas rentrer dans des détails
parce que je crois que je sortirai de
mon rôle et du mandat qui m'a été donnée
mais un président par exemple ça ne se
déplace pas seul donc il faut organiser
l'alimentation des personnes qui se
déplacent avec lui
quand il se déplace il faut prévenir des
personnes à l'endroit où ils se
déplacent c'est ça le rôle du chargé de
mission du chef de cabinet dans la
réalisation des déplacements non
publique du président de la république
donc il avait également ce rôle a
répliqué nous répartition en fonction
d'un tour que je décide et de ses
missions donc voilà donc ses fonctions
elles ont été extrêmement clair depuis
le début cadrée est arrêté par mes soins
sous l'autorité du directeur de cabinet
pourquoi monsieur ben alors avait-il un
véhicule de service un peu étonné ça
peut peut être choqué parce que monsieur
benalla il passait ses journées et le
début de ses nuits au palais comme on le
fait tous pour organiser les
déplacements du président de la
république
il n'était donc pas étonnant qu'on
puisse lui confier un véhicule pour se
rendre sur les lieux de ses missions et
le soir pour rentrer chez lui le matin
pour en revenir c'est précisément la
définition d'un véhicule de service
deuxièmement sur les moyens lumineux et
sur les avertisseurs sonores dont
étaient dotés le véhicule il se trouve
que l'ensemble du parc de véhicules de
l'elysée est doté de ses moyens lumineux
et sonore pour la simple et bonne raison
que ces véhicules peuvent être intégrés
dans des cortèges et vous savez que
quand le président de la république
circule encore tagil et fait usage de
ses moyens lumineux généralement pas
sonore d'ailleurs pour des raisons de
protection du président de la république
de bonne circulation du cortège de
sécurité des autres automobilistes donc
dire qu'il y a sur ce véhicule des
moyens est une chose c'est pas forcément
pour cela qu'ils sont utilisés et s'ils
le sont ils doivent l'être dans des
règles de sécurité que que vous
connaissez général lors de son audition
le colonel lavergne qu'il y aurait
semble-t-il général devenu général
depuis qu'ils responsable également de
la sécurité du président de la
république nous a beaucoup étonné en
tout cas moi m'a beaucoup étonné
lorsqu'il a indiqué
qui ne savait pas s'il pouvait y avoir
d'autres armes déposées des tenues
portées et qu'il n'y avait même pas à le
connaître par des agents au sein de
l'elysée
or bien sûr les gendarmes et les
policiers
une situation qui paraît tout de même un
peu étonnante
est ce que vous êtes dans la même
situation est ce que vous ignorez s'il
existe d'autres détenteurs d'un port
d'armes porteurs d'armes ou d'autres
armes qui peuvent être à l'elysée
autre que celle de ceux qui sont sous
vos ordres ou ceux qui sont sous les
ordres du gspr en général et je vous
comprends à la réponse du général
lavergne parce qu'elle repose sur le
fait que si quelqu'un à titre privé à un
port d'armes est ce que la présidence de
la république doit en avoir connaissance
ça c'est la question qu'il faut poser
qui peut être cela posera ton en tout
cas doit-on connaître de la détention
d'un port d'armes à titre privé des
agents la présence de république
à l'heure actuelle non si vous faites du
tir sportif
vous avez opérations de port d'armes et
si vous avez par extension une
autorisation de détention d'armes ou de
port d'armes
à l'heure actuelle nous n'avons pas
connaissance la question l'autre
question qui peut être et puis sensible
qui découle de celle là c est ce que les
gens qui sont détenteurs à titre privé
d'un port d'armes
peuvent-ils utilisés dans le cadre des
missions qui leur seraient confiées au
sein de la présidence
la réponse est non évidemment et dans un
cas comme dans l'autre
mais dans le second cas il existe
évidemment un contrôle ne serait-ce que
visuel voilà c'est tout ce que je peux
vous répondre
alors qu'en général la réponse parce que
moi je pense très très précis allez-y je
rejoins le ce qu'a dit le général
général d'auvergne bon prenons acte de
votre réponse mais c'est vrai que les
citoyens nous représentons les citoyens
que nous sommes peuvent être étonné que
un collaborateur de la présidence de la
république ayant un port d'armes titre
privé puisse apporter son arme a
longtemps ça ne dit palais sans que il
vous paraît ce qu'il y ait là problème
alors que vous êtes en charge de la
sécurité du palais même si ce port
d'armes est purement privée je crois
qu'il devrait y avoir quand même des
règles qui soient posés pour que vous
soyez informés de tout port d'arrivée et
de toute présence d'une arme a mené par
un collaborateur quel qu'il soit à
l'elysée voyez je sors un petit peu du
cadre habituel de notre audition où nous
nous contentons nous poser des questions
mais c'est pour vous dire la sensibilité
de la question et plus par ailleurs dans
la question de françois pilet je crois
comprendre qu'il y avait une autre
dimension
je vais essayer de la préciser saviez
vous que monsieur benalla avait un
permis de port d'armes et en quoi ce
permis de port d'armes et étaient
était-il utiles à l'exercice de sa
fonction à l'elysée peut-être que vous
même la décrivez oui je vous reviens sur
la question
la question de savoir si illégitime si
on doit être au courant de cet aspect de
port d'armes à titre privé mais le
besoin d'en connaître doit quand même à
minima reposer sur toujours la notion de
sécurité
je ne pense pas que à l'essence benalla
représenter une menace pour la
présidence de république telle que nous
la question les distingue parce que pour
monsieur benalla c'est pas un port
d'armes privé c'est important de
professionnels
donc il ya deux aspects dans la question
vient c'est pour ça qu'elle est un petit
peu complexe il ya effectivement celui
qui a un port d'arrivée
est ce que c'est normal qu'ils puissent
amener son arme au palais sans que vous
le sachiez pour un motif de sécurité
justement
et puis pour monsieur benalla et
d'éventuels autres collaborateurs du
président de la république qui aurait un
port d'armes à titre professionnel
est-ce que c'est justifié par leur
fonction et en particulier par celles de
monsieur ben à la voile et ces deux
questions en une très bien mais merci de
près de préciser c'est bien ça merci de
décortiquer la question parce que s'il
s'agit alors des collaborateurs de la
présidence qui ont un port d'armes à
titre privé c'est dire qu'on sort du
cadre doit être acquis lui un port
d'armes à titre professionnel
donc cela ne peuvent pas rentrer mais
mais je pensais que vous faisiez
référence au port d'armes dans les
centres benalla qui lui un port d'armes
à titre professionnel
ah non non ce n'est pas globale excuse
moi mais les sénateurs soit on a un port
d'armes à titre professionnel
on est dans le cas de figure alexandre
benalla auquel cas on a droit de porter
y compris dans l'enceinte du palais de
l'elysée
soit on a un port d'armes à titre privé
et là vous ne rentrez pas à l'elysée
toute façon vous passez pas par les
détecteurs déjà et ensuite à partir de
là le système de contrats ou se mettant
brand et vous êtes refoulé y compris
pour un collaborateur qui arrivent en
voiture non
et alors et et et enfin maintenant mais
cette première partie de la question et
un rayon obtenu une réponse
l'autre partie c'est effectivement est
ce que le port d'un professionnel de
monsieur pénale a été justifiée par sa
fonction telle que vous nous l'avez vous
même décrite
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas assisté
nini reporting de l'audition de du chef
de cabinet c'est à lui à apprécier si
alexandre est bien là et je d'abord est
ce qu ils sont bien là portait son arme
dans le cadre de ses missions à
l'extérieur
bon personnellement moi je n'ai jamais
vu c'était une norme qui se voyait sous
une veste pardon
alors pardon madame donc de la conterie
posera une question tout à l'heure
madame de la conterie possédons parrot
donc personnellement vous n'avez jamais
dans les missions extérieures je ne
croyais jamais elles sont bien là
puisque c'était pas mon champ de
compétences et je voudrais pas vu avec
une arme à extérieurs dont est à
l'intérieur
à l'intérieur il me semble effectivement
l'avoir vu avec une arme au retour d'une
séance de tirs je crois et il a porté en
général j'ai réagi vivement tout à
l'heure lorsque vous avez indiqué
concernant le port d'armes physique de
monsieur bénard que vous ne l'aviez pas
constaté peut-être une fois revenant
d'une séance d'entraînement et j'ai
indiqué que vous aviez dit l' inverse
lors de votre audition devant la
commission denquête de l'assemblée le 25
juillet dernier à 9h30 du matin puisque
vous avez indiquée
commençons par monsieur benalla je n'ai
vu porter une arme bien sûr dans le
cadre de certaines de ses missions tout
en précisant que cette arme n'était pas
une arme du commandement militaire donc
il n'est absolument pas dans mon état
d'esprit de vous mettre en difficulté je
souhaiterais donc que vous précisiez
dans quelles circonstances
monsieur benalla porter une arme puisque
vous l'indiqué vous même c'était dans le
cadre de certaines de ses missions bien
sûr sachant que cette commission un
petit peu de mal à comprendre quelles
étaient les missions réelles de monsieur
benalla et si oui ou non il était chargé
de la sécurité du président de la
république sur les circonstances du port
d'armes dyson bendaoui j'ai vu à
l'essence benhadda porter une arme
je ne veux bien sûr je ne renie pas ce
que j'ai dit aux auditions
c'était une revient c'est que j'ai vu
également porter son arme au retour
d'une séance de tirs
parce que ce jour-là il m'avait il me
l'avait montré plus physiquement si je
puis dire
mon général tout à l'heure j'ai fait
état d'une citation trimer de monsieur
ben alla selon laquelle les
flexion projet au sein de l'elysée
suscité une opposition du ministère de
l'intérieur
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
dire à ce sujet ou est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui à votre avis n'existe
pas écoutez nous n'avions pas encore
réellement commencer la phase des
relations interministériel comme je
voulais expliquer dans le diagramme de
de programmation de la montée en
puissance et de la création de la dsp r
tous les groupes de travail n'ont pas
été activés au même monde et le groupe
de travail interministériel lui va être
activé devrait être activée dans l'est
dans les jours qui viennent car au
préalable
je préférais nous préférerions avoir une
infection déjà un peu mature sur
l'endroit où nous souhaitons aller
le point a atteint pour la ds père avant
de présenter quelque chose au ministère
de l'intérieur et d'entamer la phase de
présentation discussions remise à niveau
enfin quelque chose qui est complètement
consubstantielle à la création d'une
nouvelle structure dont le ministère de
l'intérieur serait bien sûr partie
prenante
donc voilà
je pense que ça répond un peu à votre à
votre question à voir après qu' il y ait
de manière doctrinal au sein du
ministère l'intérieur des oppositions et
que ceux à ce projet et qu'elle se soit
manifesté elles sont bien là je jouais
bien croire je sais aussi qu'il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de d'opinion qui
sont tout à fait favorables au sein même
du ministère de l'intérieur à la
création d'une telle structure
puisqu'elles répondent comme je voulais
préciser au préalable un réel besoin de
sécurité
donc voilà je pense qu'au ministère de
l'intérieur il doit y avoir également
une pluralité de voix et de sentiments
sur la ds père mais dans un cadre
général
cette direction ne porte en rien
atteinte au ministère de l'intérieur ne
porte en rien atteinte à ces à ses
prérogatives et ne porte en rien
atteinte à sa présence future dans le
cadre de la protection du président de
république ça je peux d'ores et déjà
vous vous le confirmer dans le cadre de
ses déplacements du président de la
république je peux avoir des contacts
sur le terrain avec les services de
l'elysée comme la chaufferie du cabinet
le j'espère voir le commandement
militaire
or la question du 1er mai 2018
j'ai ainsi rencontré l'ancien adjoint au
chef de cabinet du président de la
république monsieur ben alla alexandre
une dizaine de fois dans le cadre de
dispositifs prévus par note de service
ces services n'ont pas soulever de
difficultés particulières pour moi
autorités civiles à la direction de
l'ordre public et de la circulation
monsieur benalla était l'adjoint au chef
du cabinet du président de la république
il était en charge de l'organisation et
de la coordination des services sur les
déplacements du président sur plusieurs
aspects comme la sécurité générale où le
protocole en tant que chef adjoint de
cabinet monsieur ben alors exprimé les
souhaits et les demandes de la
présidence de la république
je vous précise que je n'entretiens que
des relations professionnelles avec
monsieur banal a je ne les ai jamais vus
en dehors d'un dispositif de service
d'ordre prévu par note de service
je vous vois monsieur benalla je
l'appelle monsieur ben alla ce dernier
m'appelle commissaire et me vouvoie je
n'ai pas le numéro de téléphone de
monsieur ben alla et je n'ai aucune
relation de copinage ou d'amitié avec
monsieur benalla jeunes entretien avec
lui que des relations strictement
professionnel dans le cadre de service
d'ordre prévu par une note de service
je veux maintenant est à votre
disposition
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs pour répondre à vos questions
je vous précise simplement comme vous
l'avez fait monsieur le président je
vous en remercie que je ne pourrais pas
répondre aux questions portant sur
l'effet du 18 et du 18 juillet faits
pour lesquels je suis mis en examen dans
cette affaire je vous dirais simplement
que dans cette affaire
j'estime n'avoir commis aucune faute de
nature pénale
et je me considère comme un
fonctionnaire de police loyal et honnête
et intègre pour moi autorités civiles à
la direction de l'ordre public et de la
circulation
monsieur benalla était l'adjoint au chef
du cabinet du président de la république
il était en charge de l'organisation et
de la coordination des services sur les
déplacements du président de la
république sur plusieurs aspects comme
la sécurité générale et le protocole il
faut prendre la phrase en soi globalité
c'est organisation et coordination des
services en matière de sécurité générale
donc ça veut dire qu' il n'est il ne
fait pas de la sécurité générale pape
accueilli y coordonne le service qui
fonda si tu étais général voilà ça c'est
pour répondre très clairement qu'il n'y
ait aucune ambiguïté
quand quant aux propos et à l'image que
je me fais de la mission de monsieur ban
à la première question
seconde question la question d
interpeller du jardin des plantes
je ne suis pas rentré madame la
sénatrice
dans le jardin des plantes je suis resté
au portillon du jardin des plantes
un autre commissaire de police ainsi
qu'une compagnie républicaine de
sécurité ont souvent trait sur
instruction au sein du jardin des
plantes pour réaliser un certain nombre
d'interpellations puisqu'il était
prouvée et je les ai vues de mes propres
yeux qu'un certain nombre d'individus
cagoulés gantés armés qui avaient
participé aux dégradations du boulevard
de l'hôpital avait pu bénéficier d'une
complicité ouvrir le portail du jardin
des plantes et fuir à l'intérieur moi je
ne suis pas rentré dans le jardin des
plantes et j'ai uniquement vu la fuite
de 200 individus appartenant black block
partir vers le jardin des plantes
c'est très clair là dessus c'est
extrêmement clair et est d'ailleurs tout
toutes nos zones sont enregistrés nous
nous on donne aux ondes radio 1
et tout ça a été passé sur les ondes
radio je me suis arrêté si vous aussi
vous connaissez un petit peu le secteur
devant le mcdonald's ça c'est pour la
seconde question
la troisième question la question des
observateurs donc je traiterai soucier
vous souhaitez qu'on fasse différemment
mais je te retrait que de la question
des observateurs du 1er mai peut-être ça
vous ça vous suffira moi j'ai appris le
2 mai à neuf le 1er mai par dont le
premier mais excusez moi j'ai appris le
1er mai à 9 heures lors de ma prise de
service à ligne de la cité que monsieur
benalla serait présent comme observateur
sur le dispositif de manifestation
revendicative du 1er mai je l' ai appris
de la bouche du numéro 3 de l'année au
pc c'est un contrôleur général
pourquoi est-ce que je les a pris jallet
a pris puisque ce contrôleur général à
son bureau à côté du bien et qui se
trouve que le major de police qui était
le tuteur de monsieur ben alla le 1er
mai à son bureau en face donc aux cafés
comme quand vous venez au travail
tous les jours au café ce contrôleur
général ahmadi en discutant également
avec le major de police qui étaient
présents que monsieur ben alla serait
présent en tant qu'observateur il n'y
avait aucune question problématique
soulevée à ce moment là puisque nous
accueillons très souvent des
observateurs moi même je suis souvent
désigné comme étant tuteur quand des
organes commandes des observateurs
viennent voir des services lors de la
démo pc je les fais sur les quatre
derniers mois avec un journaliste de m6
par exemple l'inde enquête exclusive de
moi je les fais avec un membre du
cabinet du préfet de police
il se trouve que là le premier mais je
n'étais pas désigné je n'étais pas
désigné comme étant le tuteur ne
mentionnait là puisque c'était le major
de police
j'ai eu cette information simplement
parce que nous partageons les presque
deux bureaux ou trois bureaux sont
voisins
j'ai eu cette information dans ce
cadre-là par la suite sur cinq questions
de monsieur kraz moi je n'avais jamais
vu mes secrets en premier mais je ne
l'identifié pas et d'ailleurs j'ai
appris ça nous son identité un monsieur
crade ainsi que son statut
de mémoire le le 19 juillet lors du
point presse de monsieur bruno roger
petit jeune a pris à ce moment là qui
vous avez terminé monsieur creuse un peu
puis je crois voir répondre aux
questions j'ai d'autres questions mais
madame le rapporteur souhaite imposer
une aussi oui merci monsieur le
président une question précisément sur
le statut d'observateur d'ordre général
nous avons beaucoup discuté sur
l'équipement qui fournit aux
observateurs en tant que tuteur est ce
vous qui décidez de cet équipement et
pouvez vous nous dire en quoi il
consiste puisqu'en tant que tuteur vous
devez le constater physiquement
avant de répondre à votre question même
le co-rapporteur je vais également vous
préciser la procédure qui m'amène à être
désignée comme tuteur lors d'un autre ça
lorsqu un observateur vie revient à voir
un service d'ordre à la des opc la
demande est faite au cabinet du préfet
de police le cabinet du préfet de police
rebascule la demande valider ou non
validée au des opc le des opc rebascule
cette demande au chef d'état major qui
est mon supérieur hiérarchique direct et
le chef d'état-major désigne moi même ou
un des 14 autres commissaires de police
de la direction pour être le tuteur
c'est comme ça que ça se passe là des
opc est une est une maison extrêmement
erard chizé nous exerçons en tenue et la
circulation de l'information
opérationnelle extrêmement codifié une
fois que j'ai entre guillemets le sésame
on me dit mais se creuse à vous allez
accueillir un observateur à telle date
pour telle manifestation géant general
également le statut de cette source cet
observateur et ce qui peut voir on va
dire que le journaliste de m6 qui vient
pour avoir des images un petit peu on va
dire spectaculaire de l'ordre public
pour un reportage télé n'aura pas
forcément le même besoin elles mêmes
demandes en tant qu'observateur que à
quelqu'un du défenseur de droits
donc je prend également en compte cette
information-là et des instructions du
cabinet du préfet de police
accompagnant général le statut de
l'observateur ça c'est pour le
cheminement que ce soit ce soit bien
clair je ne décide pas moi même d'être
tuteur est de prendre quelqu'un c'est
pas du tout comme ça que ça fonctionne
sur la deuxième question la question de
l'équipement
effectivement il est courant voire même
permanent en tout cas je le fais à
chaque fois quand j'ai un observateur
avec moi je lui donne un casque de
maintien de l'ordre
un casque de maintien de l'ordre pour
que ce dernier puisse se protéger
on a en
assez souvent moi j'exerce en tenue en
tenue d'uniforme si vous voulez à la
tête
en tant qu'autorité civil à la tête de
fonctionnaires des compagnies
américaines de sécurité ou des escadrons
de gendarmes mobiles
j'ai ce qu'on appelle une combinaison
tactique avec un certain nombre de
protections
on prend assez souvent des projectiles
même sur des manifestations de de
moyenne intensité ça peut être juste une
bouteille de bière je t'ai si vous
voulez donc il faut que l'observateur
puisse être protégé un casque première
chose je j'anticipe un vous les deux
autres questions qui vont être le
brassard police et l'acropole
puisque vous ne l'imposé pas mais je
vais vous répondre quand je suis tuteur
et encore une fois je n'étais pas
désigné de cutter le 1er mai je vous
parle de quand moi je suis tu perds dans
l'observateur de manière générale cela
ne me choque pas cela ne me choque pas
qu'un observateur et un poste acropole
pdg pour écouter la radio
pourquoi puisque c'est également liée à
sa sécurité
le message qu'on passe sur les ondes
radio et éminemment important on dit où
sont les forces en présences ou peuvent
être les perturbateurs ou peuvent être
les casseurs il faut que l'observateur
est également cette information là quand
je suis tuteur je vais pas passer la
moitié de mon service d'ordre a expliqué
à l'observateur ce qui se passe il peut
avoir une radio pour écouter en temps
réel et à voir ces informations d'al qui
sont des informations empirique qui sont
liées au maintien de l'ordre auxquelles
ils assistent et il ya une logique à ce
qu'ils aient tous tout le cheminement de
pensée jeunes et sur mes trois dernières
années au pc jamais jamais d'ailleurs
c'est totalement impossible je n'ai
jamais vu un observateur parler à la
radio et je peux vous le dire vous ne
posez pas la question mais je peux vous
répondre
monsieur ban à la nappe a parlé à la
radio le premier mais c'est impossible
le réseau radio delà des opc le réseau
radio 2 c est un réseau extrêmement
hérarchie zay ont peu de personnes par
an
par dessus avec une discipline ce qu'on
appelle une discipline sur les ondes qui
est extrêmement rigoureuse avec des ânes
idée indicatif radio traçable donc moi
je parle souvent à la radio à la dopc je
peux vous dire que les observateurs ne
parle jamais à la radio ou même sur leur
prête à un poste c'est uniquement un
poste pour écouter et que monsieur ben
ali n'a pas parlé à la radio le premier
sur la question du brassard alors moi
j'exerce en tenue d'uniforme comme je
voulais dit l'observateur peut être en
tenue civile et accompagnés des
policiers en uniforme
dans ce cadre là dans ce cadre là même
si effectivement d'un point de vue
réglementaire
ça ça peut soulever une difficulté mais
à partir du moment où l'observateur va
être tout le temps avec moi si je suis
amené à passer des barrages moi je les
passerai il faut pas que l'observateur
soient bloqués il faut qu'ils puissent
être identifiés comme appartenant aux
professionnels de l'ordre public donc là
aussi il n'est pas choquant que ce
brassard soient prêtés
[Musique]